tú
[Música]
en los primeros años de universidad al
subir en uno de estos buses del
transporte público la ruta 51 muy famosa
por los actos de delincuencia se sube un
chico y se sienta a la par mía
me dice qué onda qué onda
cómo estás bien
pues ahí eso empezó una buena
conversación le conté que ibas a la
universidad que estaba estudiando arte
él me contó que no había podido seguir
estudiando
yo lo animé a que como pude ahí a que
siguiera avanzando y todo y se nos fue
el tiempo y pues en algún momento me
dice
y vos fijate que tengo un arma
en serio el chilero sin saber qué más
decir
me dice creo que no era la respuesta
también que esperaba y al rato me dice
quieres que te la muestre
no no no por qué vas a asustar a la
gente elige y después de de un momento
así en silencio me dice vos yo lo que
quiero es que me esté celular y más
sorprendidos todavía
elige en serio
al menos deja de sacarle el chip porque
la otra vez me costó un montón conseguir
los contactos ligeros y ya desesperado
me quitó el teléfono y se bajó del bus y
pues esta es una escena muy común al
menos en la parte de quitar celulares y
la delincuencia en un país en vías de
desarrollo como guatemala y pues yo la
delincuencia acá es es común yo crecí en
en un barrio
y como en todo barrio
cómo
que marginado como que se conoce como
como le llaman a esto
como zonas rojas
pues uno ve muchas cosas
complicadas y tristes como recuerdo
algunas algunas ocasiones desde el bus
observar que alguien está disparando al
de la tienda y luego verlo salir y que
alguien lo está esperando en un picop y
y se desaparecen a la vuelta de la
esquina e impunes o alguien también
esperando el bus y que de repente
aparece un tipo y dispara sin más
hay muchas escenas muchas escenas
tristes y el punto es que las todas las
cifras que escuchamos de delincuencia y
violencia en guatemala
son experiencias difíciles y complejas
que nos tocan que vivir a diario
pues bueno yo soy mi nombre es johnny
corado y estoy estudiando arte
ahora estoy en mi ips finalizando y pues
he tenido una muy buena experiencia en
esto soy uno de los afortunados que pudo
seguir tomando el bus hacia la
universidad
pues en esta ruta violenta que me tocó a
mí que que subir para el conocimiento he
aprendido algunas cosas que me gustaría
exponerles la primera es que no son
suficientes las decisiones personales
para construirse un camino de bien o un
camino hacia el conocimiento
definitivamente los factores externos
influyen en las decisiones personales
por ejemplo con la experiencia de este
chico en el bus en ese momento yo no yo
no me pregunte porque este chico tan
joven
quería quitarme el celular
qué cosas tenía el será que tenía las
mismas oportunidades que yo tuve porque
yo cuando tenía su edad nunca se me
ocurrió cómo venir a asaltar a la gente
o voy a ir a quitar celular de uno que
hay que hay de diferencia entre él y yo
y por otro lado como es que un chico tan
joven puede conseguir un arma donde la
consiguió quien se la vendió como es que
esto es posible aquí en este país
esto por un lado luego lo otro en
segundo lugar que
tenemos una la estructura de nuestra
sociedad es como si estuviera por
esferas pequeñas esferas donde la gente
se relaciona entre sí y creas sus
culturas con su propio con su propia
códigos de lenguaje actividades las
cosas que valoran
y de esta manera encontramos pequeñas
esferas de acuerdo al nivel
socioeconómico de acuerdo a las etnias
y éstas no se relacionan entre sí aunque
no significa que no haya contacto entre
ellas
y esto sucede porque hay muy pocos
espacios donde gente de diferentes
esferas puede coincidir por ejemplo si
tuviéramos una muy buena educación un
sistema de educación público o un buen
sistema de espacios recreativos donde la
gente optará por ir de diferentes
esferas entonces esto nos abriría la
oportunidad de crear relaciones con
otros y finalmente ya no nos parecería
tan extraño el otro y las diferencias se
van diluyendo y uno descubre que al
final no somos tan diferentes los unos
de los otros
en tercer lugar otro conocimiento es que
la universidad y el conocimiento en sí
nos va abriendo la más la perspectiva
y va rompiendo los propios paradigmas
los propios dogmas que uno puede tener
para por fin salir de uno mismo y poder
encontrarse junto a los otros y ver a
alguien más
[Música]
sí y además la el conocimiento no sólo
nos permite
reconocernos a nosotros mismos con
nuestros propios límites sino que nos da
las herramientas para poder entrar a la
esfera de alguien más pues bueno seguir
yendo a la universidad y sin sin darme
cuenta o dando por sentado muchos
conocimientos
fui descubriendo mucho sobre la historia
de la música el pentagrama las notas
musicales los dos personajes que
escribieron y cosas tan sencillas como
esto me di cuenta que no no todos lo
tienen por ejemplo esto
[Música]
es tan sencillas como una vocalización
descubrí que son conocimientos muy
importantes que podrían abrirnos las
posibilidades hacia nosotros
vamos a intentar algo bien sencillo van
a repetir después de mí de acuerdo vamos
[Música]
harán
ah
tan tan tan tan tan
[Música]
ah
taca taca patatas
[Música]
e
y está bueno
como los pequeños conocimientos por más
sencillos que sean podrían darnos la
oportunidad de conectar con otras
personas
pues
siguiendo a la universidad y este ir y
venir generó muchos conocimientos fui
conociendo a mucha gente y estas
lecturas los documentales videos estas
experiencias buenas y malas los buenos y
malos catedráticos van formando un
criterio sobre la vida y nos van
permitiendo descubrirnos y descubrir la
realidad y llega un momento tiene que
llegar un momento donde la esfera
personal no es suficiente y nos
encontramos
con los otros y creo que eso puede
suceder o debería suceder con el
conocimiento y que también esto puede
hacer que nosotros tengamos nos hagamos
más preguntas cuando sucede cualquier
cosa
en nuestro país y todo entonces hay un
momento en el que yo escuché sobre los
amotinamientos en las gaviotas un centro
de detención para adolescentes en
conflicto con la ley
pues decidí a partir de convicciones a
partir de las cosas que yo había
descubierto un poco de un documental que
me hizo descubrir el potencial de la
música para la reinserción social lo que
podía hacer y decidí proponer un
proyecto de guitarra y canto para
adolescentes en conflicto con la ley
penal y permítanme contarles mi
experiencia el primer la primera semana
las imágenes que tengo es que este día
el primer día que llegué me recibieron
desde una ventanita y era un mundo
completamente desconocido para mí
y sabía lo que ustedes saben lo de los
amotinamientos constantes las muertes
que han habido sabía también de las de
las cosas muy amarillistas que conocemos
de los adolescentes pero en realidad no
sabía nada de lo que es de lo que sucede
adentro y hay muchas cosas que contar de
esta experiencia pero quisiera limitarme
a 33 experiencias la primera semana
recuerdo que yo estaba esperando a los
chicos en un salón que me asignaron y
ellos entraron con grilletes en las
manos en los pies
eran cinco chicos y un montón de
monitores en el mismo salón
y pues comenzamos yo empecé con ellos
explicándoles sobre el proyecto y en
esta explicación sobre el proyecto
comencé cantándoles también un par de
canciones y en una de esas canciones en
la nota más aguda uno de los chicos se
dio un ataque de risa y yo empecé a
entre risas y seguí cantando y cuando
termine le dije ay te dio un ataque de
risa y le seguí explicando el proyecto
al final de la primera clase uno de los
chicos se acerca y me dice
mira
y quería agradecerte por venir acá
a nosotros nos tienen miedo pero vos
decidiste venir y quería pedirte
disculpas por el homie que se rió porque
nosotros no estamos acostumbrados a esto
me dijo y sus palabras este chico me
afirmó estaba en el lugar correcto y es
que
cada vez que yo contaba sobre este
proyecto la gente se encargaba de
decirme lo peor que había escuchado del
centro de privación de libertad todas de
todo tipo de anécdotas no sobre esto
y la verdad es que con esto descubrí que
precisamente por lo que escuchamos
precisamente porque hay peligro
precisamente porque hay convulsión y es
difícil porque si hay peligro si hay con
convulsión y si es difícil es porque hay
mucha mucha necesidad allí adentro
bueno otra otra experiencia uno
una de los objetivos que tenía como
proyecto era acercarlos a la música pero
también acercarlos a tres valores a
través de la música uno era la belleza
el amor y la fuerza
y la belleza era todos podemos sentir
belleza todos podemos disfrutar de lo
bello y podemos crear belleza de la
fuerza que tenemos fuerza no para abusar
de otros sino para ayudar a otros
hablamos de muchas cosas y lo hicimos a
través de el arte también a través de
audiciones de un poema de una de poemas
de un cuento y de algunas películas que
elegí para este proyecto y una de esas
audiciones que que pasé es una canción
que un amigo me recordó
esta canción dice así
adiós
él
entre piedras
y rincón en este río marrón que hacen
aquí tan
de lima
qué hacen aquí
estos pequeños
lejos del hogar que hacen aquí
entre piedras entre hiedra y dolor en
este río marrón que hacen aquí lejos del
hogar
y hacen aquí
estos amadas
en este lugar
ven aquí
/ piel entre hierbas y candor en este
parque de amor que hacen aquí
lejos de la razón
lejos del amor
lejos del cielo
como una alma perdida un sol sin vida
qué hacen aquí los desvelos
qué hacen aquí sin un consuelo
[Música]
pues después de escuchar la canción
hice un par de preguntas
y después de reconocer que hay un lugar
para cada cosa que las gaviotas tienen
el mar que los niños deberían de estar
en un lugar que incluso para los amantes
hay un lugar
les pregunté bueno y ahora les digo a
ustedes que hacen aquí
qué hacen aquí y fue increíble ver
ustedes tendrían que acercarse a ellos o
estar ahí y ver sus sus rostros su
mirada para darse cuenta lo que un
pequeño conocimiento puede tener en el
lugar adecuado un conocimiento tan
sencillo como una canción
y pues bueno seguir compartiendo con
ellos si tenía la oportunidad incluso de
compartir en la mesa y un día uno de los
chicos me preguntó profe y usted alguna
vez se ha sentido triste me dijo yo no
sé si pueden entender la profundidad de
esta pregunta pero allí estaba el otro
ya no desde mi esfera ya no desde las
noticias sino ahora en su esfera en su
lugar y ya no era tan extraño como lo
veía y ahora era un adolescente como
cualquier adolescente y la propuesta que
traigo ahora es que yo creo que es un
poco muy poco ambicioso querer tener
conocimiento solo para ganar dinero
cuando las posibilidades que tenemos
podrían transformar una realidad
que es increíble que las pequeñas cosas
que sabemos yo me sé apenas un par de
acordes me sé algunas canciones y este
conocimiento tan sencillo en un lugar
que no es mi esfera ha podido tener
cosas extraordinarias con estos chicos
pues la invitación no es a que ustedes
entren a la música y vayan y hagan un
proyecto parecido sino a preguntarnos
qué conocimientos tengo yo que podrían
generar una transformación en otro lugar
que no es el mío qué valioso puede ser
el conocimiento que tenemos en relación
a eso y por último solo quiero cantar
una última canción es
es quizá inspirada en mucha gente que ha
querido cambiar el mundo con una tesis
o querer transformar realidades unal
[Música]
el pincel
a la humanidad
viviendo en armonía
y después tarde
la ilusión egoísta que no deja ver lo
importante
que un desconocido
[Música]
es el otro que también lo es
y que un enemigo encuentre y reflejó en
su oponente por qué
el color
[Música]
suelo pensar
dando libertad
[Música]
cuando las cadenas en una historia con
ellos
y finalmente hacer
realmente su felicidad
encuentre estar en casa
su fragilidad
tales
pero pensar
la humanidad
y la cultura y religión
[Música]
para ver
d
[Música]
gracias
d
era así
y
por fin vivamos
como hermanos
no
suelo pensar
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y
[Música]